it's not even just the conservative
adults
it's the kids if the kids
in any way disobey dr fauci
they're not just terrorists but
murderers a member of an oklahoma school
board just came out during a school
board meeting and said that if kids do
not wear the masks in class they could
be murderers it's just not okay
for kids to commit murder by coming to
school without a mask and when it comes
down to it
it's
possible they will ch they will cause a
death of another child
because they come to school without a
mask
these are the people leading us
and you know this woman is hysterical
and not the brightest bulb in the pack
but i'm not sure that she's so much uh
so much more ignorant or so much uh
stupider than adam kinzinger or than
anthony blinken or any of the ruling
elite that are just getting all of this
stuff wrong first of all to this woman's
point
she just obviously doesn't know what
murder is murder involves intention so
if she's saying that kids are killing
people because they're not wearing masks
again also a ridiculous claim but that
would not be murder so she certainly
doesn't know what she's talking about
and then then to go and she's saying
look if a kid shows up to school without
a mask
he could spread
the coronavirus
because the kids are not vaccinated
right but we've also been told that
vaccinated people are spreading the
coronavirus
and we've also been told that the masks
don't offer perfect protection against
spreading the coronavirus by anthony
fauci actually of all people
so
what she's saying is
the kids could spread the coronavirus
and then if it spreads far enough you
know someone might might die from that
and maybe the masks
don't offer perfect protection to stop
that and the vaccines certainly don't
offer perfect protection to stop that
but still the kids can be involved in it
this would be
like saying
that if a guy
on an assembly line in detroit
polishes the windows on a brand new car
and then the car makes it to a
dealership somewhere else in the united
states and someone
looks at that car and says gosh that
look how beautiful that shiny windshield
is you know i think i'm going to go buy
that car and then that guy goes and buys
that car and he drives that car around
for a little bit and then maybe he
decides you know he's not going to uh
like that car anymore maybe he wants to
get a different group he goes and he
sells that car and he sells that car to
someone else and then that other person
goes and he goes to a bar one day and he
has a few too many drinks and he gets in
a car and he accidentally gets into a
car accident and somebody dies in that
car accident that windshield wiper
killed somebody
that because that got way back on the
line he did a thing
and that resulted do you realize i mean
this is now the logic that the the kovid
people
are foisting on all of us that anything
we any ordinary thing we do to live our
lives somewhere down the line of
causation could cause someone to die and
so you you are a murderer
it's not just on the covets i mean this
is this is their point on on dhs and the
terror threat of conservatives yeah
there's no threats yeah there's no
actual plots or anything but if someone
says that maybe there were shenanigans
in the 2020 election well that could
inspire someone else to maybe think
there's a problem with the government
that could inspire someone else and then
someone someday might throw a punch
against a guy at a bar and look he's a
terrorist
that logic is so muddy that logic is so
so
it's not credible
it's just
not credible
glad you liked that clip if you want to
catch the whole episode it's called
forget the taliban anti-massacres are
the real terrorists you can get it here
on youtube but really i would encourage
you to get it on apple podcasts spotify
google play stitcher wherever you get
your audio podcasts really helps us
circumvent some of the shenanigans at
big tech go over there subscribe to the
michael knowles show leave a five star
review i'll see you next time
[Music]
you